I wonder what face I'll be wearing next
time we meet can't wait
I'm your daughter Nora from the future
and I think I made a big big mistake hey
everybody it's Charlie there's a whole
bunch of flash season 5 news you've
probably seen some of this breaking
today they just named elongated man a
series regular for next year so he's
definitely coming back he'll be in most
of the episodes they also named cecile a
series regular because of her baby
and obviously the baby is a big part of
the future and this whole mistake that
Nora made the only thing that they have
not done yet this is actually really
interesting is named Nora a series
regular or even say whether or not she's
coming back at all I love how they
clearly are telling you that she's
coming back because her mistake informs
the entire season but they're being
really coy about it I think because
they're sitting on it till we get to
comic-con and then they'll say hey you
know guess what Nora's gonna be coming
she'll be in most of the episode that's
also probably when they're going to
announce who they've cast to play the
cicada villain who's gonna be the
villain in present day the villain in
the future I'll explain that in a second
and brand new flash war so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this going through
the paces next season Barry has already
been reinstated to the Central City
Police Department so he's not gonna be a
gumshoe with Ralph even though the
probably pal around doing CSI work on
the meta cases while they're trying to
take down cicada the twist of season 5
is that cicada hates metas and wants to
get rid of them all so like imagine them
on a crime scene in season 4 or even
before that like Barry during season 1 a
meta is usually the villain of the
situation they've either killed somebody
or they've taken something so they're
investigating the crime scene this time
it's all the medes in Central City that
are the victims cicada is the one
perpetrating those crimes so you can see
how through them investigating Nora's
mistake you can see metas start to die
all over Central City and then they
eventually figure out who's doing it
because they're borrowing a little bit
of comic book cicada but it
feels very similar to what the thinker
was doing instead of taking their powers
to use them himself cicada just steals
their powers and nullifies them like he
basically turns them off so imagine that
no matter how powerful someone was you
take their powers away they're just a
normal person the new version of the
reverse-flash is a big deal to remember
they teased him during the crossover
imagine what my face will look like the
next time we meet the easiest way for
them to invoke new reverse-flash is to
make Norris mistake relevant to his
character her mistake leading to the
creation of this crazy meta cicada also
threatens reverse flashes existence
because if cicada can take villains
powers away he can also take the reverse
flashes powers away the real question is
is who is the new actor going to be
that'll play that character I imagine
it'll still be a yellow version of the
costume they won't change that too much
but they'll probably be really quiet
about that so that when it shows up
it'll be like holy crap the
reverse-flash is back and it's
completely different the other big
things that they'll probably wind up
using elongated Man 4 is for Caitlin's
storyline because now it's all about her
trying to reconcile killer frost like
she found out that she's just a part of
her so we'll probably see her come back
soon maybe they'll change her costume
she got those weird goggles at the end
of last season with that black coat that
just might be a version of her season 5
costume or they might decide to change
it during the break but that gives
elongated man the opportunity to be the
reverse frosty Oprah that she was to him
during season 4 remember he was the
conflicted one she was like come on
stretch sit down so he's the person that
can do that for her now because she's
the one that's all conflicted Cecille is
important for obvious reasons she's
gonna raise the baby with Joe they have
to address that but also I think that
baby is going to be a bigger thing in
the future remember two different
timelines
there's 2048 the years that Norah comes
from where cicada has become this crazy
big villain and almost killed all the
metas you imagine that Norah was born
just a little while before this 2024
future newspaper crisis event where
Barry ended up dying
imagine Cecile's baby jenna is a little
bit older than that so maybe we'll visit
that future timeline we don't know how
much they could be going lost season 4
with this where we go between different
timelines but on lost it was mostly like
alternate timelines in the whole idea on
the flash during season 5 is
Noora messed up in the future so they
probably tried to change cicada in
present day so that he does not become
the super crazy villain in the future so
imagine a version of Back to the Future
that focused a little more on Biff's
villain character like you see how he
changes based on the way that Marty
McFly changes the past but moving in a
flash war territory so really big stuff
happening right now the pitch is is that
hunter zolomon is pitting the two of
them against each other because just
like he did back during the Wally West
era in the comics he wants to make Wally
a better speedster
but in the most psychotic way possible
so this version of Wally West in the
comics came back out of the Speed Force
during flash rebirth it was really
awesome but he barely remembers his 20
year history of comic book stories
remember he got married to Linda Park he
had twins named joy and iris he doesn't
remember any of that stuff so hunter
zolomon tells him about it and it blows
his mind we can get your children back
Wally so he's like oh my god I have to
get my children back the twist is is
that zoom says the only way to get them
back is to break the Speed Force the
only way he can do that is if he gets
Barry's help zoom has lost his speed he
does have a gavel that allows him to
manipulate time so he does have a
powerful weapon but this is all about
Wally trying to get Barry's help in
rescuing his children and of course
Barry like if you remember episode 15 of
the flash this past season where Jay
Garrick is like we are not going to
destroy the Speed Force Barry Barry's
first real big solution to getting rid
of this bomb was to throw it into the
Speed Force and Jay Garrick is like oh
hell no we're not throwing this into the
Speed Force you send the bomb into the
Speed Force let it detonate America like
hell you will
what do you mean why not because flash
if you do that we may lose the Speed
Force forever
what do you mean we might lose the
speedforce an explosion of that size
could destroy it completely if that
would have happened every speedster
across space and time would lose access
to their speed instantly every speedster
even if it got rid of Thawne and every
other evil speedster in the multiverse
you cannot do this I won't let you so
the exact same thing is happening in the
comics right now and Wally is like I
don't care about the Speed Force I want
my children in Barry's like very clearly
you gone crazy town banana pants and
you're listening to your greatest
arch-nemesis obviously there's some
ulterior motive we need to think this
through Wally doesn't want to think it
through so that's the setup
Wally's like I will make sure you never
run again if you don't help me so this
is gonna continue for a while and the
riders Josh Williamson also said that
there's a new separate flash title that
they'll be publishing later this year I
think that's a bit of a tip-off to the
idea that ginger Wally West is gonna get
his own solo flash comic book where he's
not running around with Barry all the
time and they'll bring back his
characters from the Speed Force they'll
be a part of those comic book stories so
you'll have Barry in the main flash
title then you'll have the secondary
title with the Wally West flash
african-american Wally West is a Teen
Titans character they just formed a new
roster so he's in that title like he
doesn't have his own solo flash title so
if you've had a chance to check it out
let me know what you think of flash war
and leave all your bonus video requests
in the comments below
congratulations to captain red you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here to learn all
about the flash movie and all those DC
movie previews that they dropped this
week and click here for brand new
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight